hey guys first of all I want to thank
you for all of your questions that
you're sending sending in on the survey
that I did on what videos do you want me
to do and so I'm doing a whole series of
videos based on what you want to know
about and the question that I'm going to
answer today relates to avoiding cooking
because a lot of times when you buy
these keto cooking books it takes a lot
of time to make these meals okay so I
don't spend a lot of time cooking my
meals and I'm just going to kind of give
you some ideas of what I eat and what
you can do to kind of make things quick
without spending too much time cooking
so number one you can actually buy
boiled eggs now I don't I make my own
eggs but you can buy them and it's
pretty convenient and you can add the
butter or mayonnaise or sour cream with
it to get your fat salt and pepper
so that's pretty simple with my salads I
just take salad I throw a couple things
on it I put olive oil and a vinaigrette
that's it and I eat it it's that simple
it takes me two seconds I don't spent a
lot of time making a salad okay
spinach you can sauté spinach with some
canned tuna on there okay do wild-caught
tuna or even sardines and that makes a
nice meal you can put some you know
shave some cheese on it Parmesan cheese
if you want okay and then sardines I
recently found out that sardines do have
omega-3 I sent these sardines to the lab
and it came back with high levels of
omega-3 fatty acids so might want to use
that it's a little simple it's
convenient nuts and nut butters I go
through a lot of pee cons I like
pistachios I like walnuts another thing
you can do is get the sugar snap peas
I'll eat the whole bag and I love them
and it's really high in vitamin C celery
I do a lot of celery with hummus or a
nut butter right after the meal cheese
I'm from Wisconsin I do a lot of cheese
and I'm always eating cheese with my
meals try to do the fatty of cheese is
not the low-fat cheese I also buy high
quality summer sausage at the health
food store and I might combine these two
right here sometimes they have some high
quality ham I'll I'll combine the two
protein shakes you can do something like
this a meal replacement to make it easy
which has MCT oil and the protein
mushroom with cheese is a real quick
meal I'll take the mushrooms I'll shave
the cheese I'll melt it and then I'll
have a little protein with that and on
the weekends that's when I might have a
little more time to make some keto bombs
and I'll keep those in the freezer as my
dessert in summary the truth is you
don't have to spend a lot of time
cooking you can do short cut very fast
meal preparation alright thanks for
watching so if you don't have this book
you might want to check it out it's
entitled it's not lose weight to get
healthy it's get healthy to lose the
weight healthy ketosis and in a minute
fasting check it out I put a link down
below